welcome back y'all I'm here with the
cast of book club the next chapter with
Jane Fonda Candice Bergen science team
version
so we're gonna go through some of our
personal
um book club picks um in a moment but
first um do you all prefer fiction or
non-fiction like what's your preference
usually non-fiction non-fiction yeah
yeah I just feel life is so short and
there's so much to learn so I'm not a
non-fiction Kyle what about you Candace
I agree non-fiction okay but Mary put me
on to a fiction book that I loved what
was it a Russian oh a gentleman
yeah it was a great read I loved that
book and I actually got to meet him
because I kind of fangirled out and I
love that wanted to meet him and he's
wonderful yeah he's a great writer so do
you generally gravitate towards fiction
or non-fiction well I read non-fiction
because Jane tell sends me books and
tells me this is good and you should
read this so I'm trying to keep up with
the Jane Fonda reading list but when I
go buy books it's usually fiction yeah I
love stories you know I love escapism in
that sense too it's nice yeah what about
you Diane what do you
no no I I love visuals I like books with
like lots of beautiful images and I'm
addicted to that and I have a lot of it
so if you want to come to my house and
look at my picture oh say yes
black and white that's so all the books
are rather black and white right oh
really like you've re-wrapped them oh I
know oh I was like that bad but I like
it no I it's so true I worked with this
photographer Brian Bowen Smith and he
had a book and literally the the
pictures tell such a story and it's so
cool and how you capture like people
like the story in their eyes like their
movement anything like sight like that
is so moving I agree that's nobody
usually answers with that that's nice
um what we asked you before the show
about books that you'd pick
um as your own book club selection so
let's start with Mary Mary what's you
picked a gentleman in Moscow a gentleman
in Moscow it was I also uh if if I go
back I loved books like cried the
Beloved Country and I was glad to be
able to read that in school that's
awesome I love that book what about you
Diane what did you choose you just
move on
do you do not pick a book you picked a
picture one okay okay okay yeah okay
it's okay I'm not sure that counts well
if it doesn't count it's okay it's okay
we'll move on Candace what about you me
uh I would pick uh Passage to India okay
right on why do you love that so much
why would you recommend it because I
love the feeling of the dust and the
Schmutz and the
and that you get to know India and and
these Incredible characters and that
it's beautifully written and um seems
descriptive yeah that's nice
what about you like what's your book
well it so happens I I like the book I
wrote we both love you I've written a
number of books
yeah
what can I do I was repressed because
what's happening to the planet with the
climate crisis yeah and so I went to DC
and got arrested a bunch of times
for you
and did you really yeah you're my hero I
figured that if I could turn 82 in jail
a lot of people would say well my God if
she could do it I'm gonna I'm gonna try
we've got to move from being concerned
about climate to taking action about
climate we're running out of time and so
I I wrote this book I love that
describing how you know hope is so
interesting it's very different than
optimism optimisms everything's gonna be
okay
but you don't do anything to make it so
hope
is like action with its sleeve rolled up
hope is you know don't you Greta tunberg
said something great don't go looking
for Hope look for action and hope will
be there yeah and that's what this book
is about wow what a great line yeah it's
called it's called what can I do my path
from climate despair to action yay I
encourage it's brilliant it's very good
easy read and full of information about
what to do all right I like it um so
Mary you mentioned a gentleman in Moscow
so what do you love about it though what
do you why did you recommend the book
why do you recommend it for people
um it it well I I guess because of what
we do for a living I love the creation
of characters and he just created such a
totally unique character in a unique
world and it was a story I'd never heard
anything like it before fresh very
magical book I just did want to say
about Jane's book The the thing I love
about that is big and small things
including things nobody had ever said
before that you can do for the climate
like in terms of what you invest in and
what you know Banking and everything
else it's such a brilliant book about
what you as a person can do thank you
Mary it's true yeah it's helpful that's
what's great about it all right
everybody book club the next chapter is
in theaters on May 12. it's right there
the actor's right there
[Applause]
okay see if this is giving everyone in
the audience a pair of tickets to go see
them movie
so like I said earlier last year I
launched a new initiative it's called
stranger reads
[Music]
we are inviting everyone to step outside
our reading preferences and discover
books we'd otherwise never pick up often
these book recommendations come from
total strangers it's happened to me
multiple times and I've loved every book
um has this ever happened to you have
ever seen somebody reading something and
they're so into it and you're like what
are you reading I've done that a lot
have you never done that yes okay thank
you thank you Candace
um the last time we did stranger reads
my recommendation came from Nobel prize
winning humanitarian Malala Yusuf zai
um of all people it was incredible check
this out Malala I was curious if you
wanted to share a book with me and I
would share one of my favorites with you
today of course I would love to share a
book with you last year my literacy book
club had this Memoir called aftershocks
by a debut author Nadia oyusu and she is
abandoned by her mother at age two and
our friend by her you know when her
father dies at age 13 and this is about
how this young woman has to create her
own home and her own place in the world
and the strength and courage it takes to
do that and I think it would really
resonate with you and all your viewers
Kelly so I hope you would enjoy that I
love it she's so cool y'all now I have
another book I want to recommend it's
called Genius of place it's the Life of
Frederick Law Olmsted by Justin Martin I
love this book I actually was reading a
fiction book and with my mother we were
reading this series and it was fictional
but it had historical characters in it
and so I googled this person because of
this fiction book I was reading uh
Seraphina and the Twisted staff
something like that and um it let me
down this whole path because I I have a
ranch and I I love land I think we
should leave most of it alone and as
much as possible but so he's known as
the father of landscape architecture and
he's also known yeah for Central Park
most of the major Parks here but also
even more importantly
um he the Vanderbilt several um
wealthier people back then were actually
he was the leader of why we have
national parks like it's which is
incredible because I think what's so
important about Central Park that you
just brought up is the thing I love
about learning is he was it was very
cool because in the time it was all for
the wealthy right it was all for the the
higher-ups they got to enjoy these
beautiful Parks or Gardens or things and
his whole goal what and he won a contest
with this other French architect to
actually to actually I'm giving you the
whole book right now um but anyway he
won this contest and it was so cool
because he wanted it to be for everyone
it was for all walks of people all walks
of life all culture it was which is
pretty Progressive thinking you know at
the time because most of the people
paying for it were the wealthier yeah
well so it was it's just really cool and
I thought you can learn a lot from
someone that you don't know but had such
a well-lived life and had all these
different Journeys to get to being this
huge person the documentary about him I
haven't but I've heard of it but I I
haven't seen it yet but I want to you
know I I made a movie in Connecticut
once and I used to run in those days and
I was running in a park and I could tell
by the way the park was designed I said
Olmsted designed this and I was right
yeah you can tell it's very Innovative
yeah I just think it's incredible how
people's minds think like that
artistically mine does not but now let's
get to the books from our audience
everyone brought something they cherish
and want to pass on Caitlyn has a
recommendation Caitlin what's your book
I brought the courage to be disliked
which when you talked about your 20s
being rough I had some rough 20s and
this book really it's about freeing
yourself from the Judgment of others and
freeing yourself from the Judgment of
yourself I'm going to be 35 this year
I'm getting married I just started a new
job and I feel like this book was a
complete 180 for me in order to find my
own happiness within myself so I
recognitions on all the friends
what's your book is the Secret Lives of
church Ladies by disha filial and I'm a
general manager at a black owned
bookstore in Los Angeles called
reparations club and this was definitely
one of our best sellers it deals with
the interior lives of black women in
Femmes around the church and you don't
have to be an avid churchgoer in order
to get into it because it really deals
with the morality and some of the double
standards that exist when we when we
apply them to our like real lives there
is some comedy in here there are
intergenerational conversations
happening there is desire there's
queerness and it's just an amazing it's
a beautiful beautiful book it gives
honor to the black church and the role
that it plays in the black community
while also interrogating it deeply and
how it sometimes contradicts with the
ways in which we were which we show up
and I deeply recommend it to everyone
wow yeah great job
um have either of you read each other's
books have either of you read those no
are you willing to switch and try it out
I like it I like it well let's go ahead
they're swapped um they're gonna switch
books and now everyone it's time to
switch books so turn to someone near you
if you haven't read the book that
they're holding everybody has to
exchange books I don't care who it's
with but read a different book that and
even if you think you won't find it
interesting I see Shel Silverstein up
there that's amazing
is that Where the Sidewalk Ends I love
that y'all picked that
um so much more reading for us all um to
do and I love it to be part of our
stranger reads campaign and exchange
your favorite book titles with others
just head to our show's insta story
right now you're welcome in advance
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all have a great night I'm going
[Music]